brent it's uh wonderful to see you
how are you likewise oh man what a night
i mean what an insane fiction 11 to zero
you expect a 65.
now that you've kind of sat with results
do you know what went wrong uh
to be honest i mean it's more or less
i something was up i could feel it i
could see it
smell it um brittany was too happy
my team was acting distant um
and when the stars align like that and
then you see the outcome
that's why i wasn't really as shocked as
everyone wanted me to be
i would have been more shocked if i got
the six to five
actually really yes yes it's just
when i was pulled aside seconds before
the nomination
ceremony week two i mean i know actually
this week sorry
yeah i there's nothing about me that
screams pawn
so i mean like right there you can't you
can't
oh sorry i can't say that oh wait wait
it's fine okay we're not lying
okay i was gonna say oh my god
but uh i am many things
but an idiot isn't one of them and to
know that
you're trying to use the pawn narrative
on me who's had a target on his back
since week one as soon as i walked to
the door in french you
you know verbally confirm that i
you're not fooling anyone and then the
acts of you know
putting me in the veto to help win a
veto but then targeting me in that veto
after i just went around and eliminated
the person that was on the block
and you still had derek f as a target i
mean this like i said it's
nothing makes sense the whole everything
added up to i'm the target and everyone
could try to tell me i wasn't but
i wasn't buying it and if i was
in their shoes i would do the same exact
thing because
as much as people want me to feel so
betrayed
i was doing the same thing to all of
them
and if i made it another week i would
have been evicted
next week so next week yeah so but
that's the surprising part when you said
you didn't want the veto
to be used i was like if you had that
you almost knew that it was gonna happen
why didn't you fight for it
i was trying but i got sick so i won the
first round
i so i suffer from severe motion
sickness
and i'm lucky i got to last what was
like 35 to 40 spins in the second round
before i had to be shoulders deep in a
bucket it just is what it is
uh and then xavier won right after
i was uh doing my thing so it wasn't
really like i had a choice in the matter
my mind wanted me to
keep going my body told me otherwise
oh it was just fighting against mind
over body
and the body one um i didn't want to
like puke all over the
actual track because that would have
been you know
a messy situation for everyone else i
had to follow but yeah
and like i said if it didn't happen this
week it was going to happen next week
and i needed to know where the numbers
lied
and i was willing to take that gamble
right big risk big reward
um if i was able to get the numbers and
still stay in the house
at least i knew where people were at if
i'm off that veto
i have no idea and then my you know i
was right because
like look yeah so
do you feel blindsided in any way
honestly you had a little bit bran come
on you you must be a little bit because
there is that confidence we saw
that was developing yes so the
confidence was real
but at the same time it's just just as
much as i would love to
uh win the lottery i might not right so
it's the getting the equilibrium of
i am really hoping but also at the same
time i'm very prepared
because i've seen the game the game has
uh a track record of getting rid of
people that look like big threats even
if they don't prove it
um right away it just makes the most
sense that if anyone's smart enough and
they obviously all
11 were it's just get rid of me
because christian especially none of the
gentlemen were going to vote for me
because i'm a threat
and the game was going to turn into an
individual game
most likely in the next couple weeks uh
yeah and then they'd have to compete
against me and hope that i stay true to
whatever alliance was formed
so it just makes sense and now uh i was
gonna go after christian and xavier
and competitively in any type of
endurance or physical
uh competition i i felt as though it
would be the best match
xavier said that on his goodbye message
and now christian keeps winning
and now i'm gonna christian because
you're you're
eliminating a person that hasn't done
anything to prove he's a threat
besides you know maybe getting caught in
some social game
and strategy along the way but christian
won a veto
he won a wild card and he won hoh
and now he's going to keep control you
know what i mean it's like so yeah yeah
you're getting rid of the wrong people
totally understand i would be a threat
because i was plotting against everyone
but at the same time i could help you
until that point
now it's a good luck stopping xavier and
christian because they're going to be a
force
to be reckoned with and it's interesting
because you said x
xavier did say you were a threat right
at the farewell video
he's the only one and hannah also said
in her farewell video
your arrogance played against you does
that do you believe that um she
definitely um
uh she confused my arrogance with my
confidence
we've had this discussion in the house
in front of others that
she arrogance is me rubbing people's
nose in something um arrogance is me
uh to be honest i really think there's a
fine line between
between cockiness confidence and
arrogance
and i can come off a little cocky
sometimes
but arrogance i don't believe in i don't
believe in just
being mean for no reason or putting
people down for no reason or rubbing
people's noses in something for no
reason
it's like we're a human being and it's
it's kindness is free and it's a very
easy act
to uh you know to do
and a lot of people in the house when we
had that kind of conversation at the
dinner table agreed that i was more
confident
than arrogant and but it makes for good
tv if she wants to say
now i'm glad you said that because you
know whitney came to you and gave you
advice you know
be careful what you say when you leave
the house you know she do you understand
where she was coming from with that
whole advice when she sat you down i
mean
will you take her advice yes absolutely
i i i'm very aware that i am very
uh witty and blunt and things that come
to me very quick
it's just boom it's there it's that i
don't really believe in sugar coating it
all right my past has always been
band-aids being ripped
rather than you know not my upbringing
just in general like experiences i've
dealt with
uh you can try to and that's also what
probably shaped me for the betrayal
you know i mean i've had a lot of
commitments come to an end
very abruptly and after a while you're
just like listen
time is is valuable so anything you
can't get back so if i can do the favor
and cut out all the crap and just be
like listen this is that and this is
this
hopefully you can find some value in
that because i'm not wasting your time
but it is something that i do need to
work on i've always been aware of it
um but a lot of people in the house were
coming to me for the truth
and right because you know they didn't
they knew everyone else was just telling
them what they wanted to hear
and it worked in my favor a few times as
far as with frenchie and travis and
a few others that the stories matched
right they were getting something from
me
someone else heard the same exact thing
it was travis actually came to
me and was like dude listen i don't know
if you guys watch the conversation but
he's like
what am i what are my odds what are my
shots you know in this house
with the votes and i was like dude it's
not looking good you're most likely
going home
i was like it is yeah and he was like
damn he was bummed out because i really
liked travis after we nominated
because i was part of the reason why he
was put up there with frenchie and it
was like listen just put up
travis get rid of a big fish stick to
that narrative
um but i ended up really liking travis
so who did you expect to vote for you
like the one person you were surprised
that
voted against you alyssa alyssa yeah
yeah um melissa just because uh we
like i was saying to a few others um
we had the common first couple day
experience we were targeted for reasons
that
you know were in our country yeah and we
i you know i didn't i told her i was
gonna put her and christian up if i was
hoh first week it just made sense it
says the same thing the christian
um he liked her they were on the same
team
they had a reason to go up as far as a
potential you know
alliance yeah final two but
then french she put her in our
slaughterhouse alliance
and so i was like now i have to try to
save her and kylan
and keep derek x off without my team so
it ended up working out but
um yeah we had a bond and her goodbye
message too was
i understand why she said what she said
because i had to do the same same exact
thing to get my
team not to be afraid of me being
friends with her well you know like
we're going to hang out after this she
wants me
for halloween and everything yeah you
know i mean
how was your experience overall did you
were you surprised by i mean were you
prepared or do you just feel like this
was the best
experience you've had i am all about
experiences i would have done this for
free i would have done this for
none of the perks that come afterwards i
really truly
enjoy being uncomfortable and um
when you put yourself in a situation
like that you learn a lot about yourself
and what you can handle what you can
live without like for everyone out there
that
doesn't think they can live without
their phone or tv or
like you can right it's proof yeah you
can yeah
and thrive and still you know uh
be who you are so that was all
you know something i was looking forward
to and i will say this
watching it and playing it two different
things
two different things entirely whoever
thinks that they would be able to uh
balance this or do that do that
differently it's so much harder
when you don't have privacy and you
don't have
a places to go without making it look
you know suspicious or it's just
everyone's whispering it is wild it's
truly an experience of a lifetime
awesome so who do you think will win
hannah easily who do you
really who do you want to win uh
christian
and who do you think shouldn't win uh
anyone that floats or coasts without
actually truly playing the game hannah
doesn't fit into that category i think
she's a mastermind
i think christian for the fact that he's
winning everything
and still has a very strong uh
you know bond with his team and with
whatever alliances he's working with
for anyone to not see that and look at
me more of a threat
i mean kudos to him he deserves to keep
winning and he deserves to keep
you know crushing the house and he does
he does this thing where he makes
he makes like octopus hot dogs and stuff
like that like the kid like is a genius
because everyone just overlooks it you
know what i mean it's just like
and he and he's a very sweet guy and
he's a
you know a great guy but he's playing
that so well if that's not him
with doctors hot dogs and it's like how
the hell can you vote on a guy that
makes octopus
you can't you just can't vote
[Laughter]
it was wonderful talking to you and i
love the fact that you said that you've
learned a lot about yourself through
this experience and you know watching
you
has been entertaining and uh
congratulations on making it this far
and hopefully we'll see in the future so
thank you so much for chatting with us
absolutely guys thank you
you